America's heroin epidemic has become
impossible to ignore the numbers are
staggering nearly half a million
Americans say they used heroin in the
past 30 days heroin overdoses more than
tripled between 2010 and 2014 and deaths
from all opioids including heroin are
now approaching the number of deaths
from car crashes so how did we get here
pain so here's the situation there's a
grim connection between opioid
painkiller addiction and heroin
addiction in this country in the 90s
doctors turned to drugs like oxycontin
vicodin and percocet to remedy what was
seen as widespread under treatment of
chronic pain the number of opioid
prescriptions filled in 1990 to 79
million by 2012 that number rose a lot
to 217 million as those numbers
skyrocketed the federal government
forced drug makers to make prescription
painkillers harder to abuse at the same
time heroin from Afghanistan Mexico
became a cheaper and more readily
available alternative the result is four
or five new heroin users in the US have
said they previously misused
prescription pain relievers so this
really is a gateway drug the
prescription drugs become a gateway to
hell now here's the argument heroin and
opiate addiction are leaking into the
political election Republicans Donald
Trump and Ted Cruz are proposing to seal
the border got a close up the borders
the drugs are pouring in because you've
got Mexican cartels that are smuggling
vast amounts of heroin into this country
Democrats Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders we need to understand that
addiction is a disease not a criminal
activity and instead move it to where it
belongs as a health issue for now Obama
is seeking 1.1 billion in
to reduce heroin deaths he's also
ordering state Medicaid programs to
cover drug treatment that leaves the
medical community needs to figure out
how to limit abuse and addiction while
also being able to effectively treat
those in real pain